hey what's up guys my name is Jonah and
welcome to episode 19 of network chat
programming so today we're gonna talk
about unique identifiers now this
episode is actually probably going to be
a lot more interesting than you think
because I'm going to cover a few
different ways and this is this is just
one of those things that's just really
cool and that you should know as a
program indefinitely essentially let's
look at our problem first right now the
problem that we have is when the client
you know receives essentially a packet
here you can see over here that we have
this this process right and what happens
over here is essentially we add a new
server client you know if the packet
starts with C we add a new server client
so that of course the server can keep
track of what clients are connected to
it and over here in serve a client we
have this parameter called ID and what
this ID is for is to basically I guess
differentiate clients from each other so
it is possible okay to connect to
clients from these same IP address for
example right there might be other
people in your house that are using a
computer in that house that is connected
to that router to the same router and
that also will send a packet of course
to this server if they're both connected
to the chat program and that'll be from
the same ip address now the same port
and same IP address that's possible as
well okay it's not you know it's it's a
lot less likely but it's possible so we
can't use that as a means of unique
identification so what can we use well
the best way to really do this is to
just generate a random number now a lot
of you guys might be like okay well
that's simple to know why don't we just
go ahead and type new random dot you
know next int okay won't that work and
we'll have to import the random class
blah blah let's just look into that
right so let me just this might be a bit
wide for you guys so I'll just call it
random so int random which will be our
random number
you know can't we just do that that'll
generate a random integer right of
course this will generate around an
integer and that the maximum number
there
the range of all possible values is 2 to
the power of 32 okay very very very big
number now that being said right that
being said it's completely it's actually
possible to get the same number okay now
I don't know it's very very unlikely I'm
just gonna put it that way it's
extremely unlikely for you to actually
get the same number twice okay in one
frickin lifetime well maybe not a lot of
time but in one like operation so in
other words if a client connects and
gets like the number let's just say we
get the random number of that yeah for
the client for the second cloud to
connect and actually get the same number
again right is actually possible okay
let's be honest in the real world it's
very very unlikely but it is possible
that's a problem now the second thing we
could do is of course use use on
something called secure random ok so
there's actually another class in Java
called secure random and we if we use
secure random and of course we'll have
to yes you're on I'm not next and I'll
see you around I'm not next and specify
how many bits we want you know whatever
that'll be fine but it you know like
that the problem with that is that it's
still gonna be possible okay now let's
just let's just go over slightly what's
secure Adam is secure random is a it's a
class that that instead of generating
essentially 2 to the power of 32 I don't
know if the listed here I should note
that didn't it's essentially 128-bit so
it's 2 to the power of 128 ok rather
than 2 to the power of 32 now that is a
hell of a lot more numbers that are
possible from there ok a lot more it's a
very it's a it's a much more secure
random non generator that being said
again it is possible for you to get the
same number twice now we're talking like
freaking ridiculous like you'd have to
run this application for I don't know
literally centuries or something to get
that number twice
okay now that's because there's so many
of them okay now that being said it's
still not the safest practice to use
secure anthem okay and there isn't us on
the service practices because however
menu school the chance it is still
possible to get the same number twice
now
that's where Java has an awesome class
called you-you-you-you ID okay and that
stands for unit universally unique
identifier so basically what we can do
and this is what we'll probably use but
I'll show you one more method because
this might not be clear UUID and we can
call it you know like a client ID or
something equals UUID
dot dot random UUID okay and then what
we'll actually have to do with that is
because we can't actually get like you
know we could push it to a string or
something and we could do a million
things yeah the the the most common
sequence here let me just
the most common thing to do here is
simply you know it's just treated like a
two string essentially okay so if we
were to print out what this would be
just to just so you guys can see this so
system dot out dot print line and we'll
print you know ID to strength which will
just be we could just put ID there okay
if we run this as a server here and that
crashed let's make sure that we change
this to ID dot two string and we might
have to adjust a few little things
because I don't think that I don't think
that this will let us do this because
it's more than just an integer here it's
more of a like a hexadecimal long or
something but if we run this for the
purposes of this from now and this is
this will probably crash yeah but we'll
say let's let's run that
okay sweet let's run our client I'll
feed her name localhost
and 1 min 2 is the port hit login ok we
crashed now check out that identifier
which will have to convert to a string
but look at that this is the identify
that you gave us look at that that's
massive okay and not only is that
massive because remember this is an in
decimal form and isn't hexadecimal
format not only is this massive it's
unique and it's guaranteed to be
universally unique on this system ok so
that's actually our problem solved now
that being said if you want to because
this is a ridiculous way of doing this
right like it's not 100% ridiculous it
might not be it not might not be the
most manageable thing to do these
numbers are huge and they might just be
unnecessary for our case ok and that's
fine like that's fine you know if if
that's unnecessary for you then you
don't have to use it so what is the
actual what is the way that we can
generate a unique identifier for the
server well let's make a new class here
so that I can demonstrate this a bit AVO
and we'll call this will call this
unique identifier ok
so public now this has to be a static
class that's important they can't be
multiple instances of this class so it
has to be a static class so what I'll
just write away I just make a private
constructor so that we can't
accidentally instantiate this class ok
private identify Oh what have you done
Joe not Java Eclipse
ok so probably unique private unique
identifier and then what we'll do is
make a public what we'll do here is
we'll make a private static int integer
array here we'll call it IDs ok now
we'll set that equal to new integer now
here you must decide ok you have to in
fact you don't want I think what we
could do
it's probably going to be better yeah
okay what I'm going to do this way what
we'll do is we'll make it we'll make it
yeah okay we'll make it an array list of
integers and I'll explain why in a
minute so we have this we have this idea
IDs equals new ArrayList integer and
then we'll set a size to it so over here
in I guess morally a size but let's
import this we need to somehow fill it
with I think we have to somehow fill it
with with values so I'll make a public
static void in it
Oh in fact you know what now it doesn't
we don't need that what we could do is
this might be a bit new but we could
just use static here and say that for in
I equals 0 I is less than now here you
have to decide your value so private
vinyl pop private static final int I
guess range
it calls 100 now what this range is is
the amount of possible identifies that
we want to generate okay so if we change
this to something like 100 what that
will enable us to do is basically have
100 unique clients connected now 100
clients might be too little okay or when
a client leaves and rejoins you might
want to up that value and that's cool
because we can always reuse identifies
don't forget but for the purposes of
this I think 100 gonna be patent gonna
be plant and plenty so I'll make a
I'll make a full loop de loops through
all of this and for each of these I'll
actually go IDs dot add and we'll just
add I to it okay so it's gonna add the
number 0 through 99 into these IDs loop
now what a static do because this class
is a static class and we should probably
put this and obviously there because
because this class is going to be like a
static class this will run without any
method so what we could have done is
gone public static you know void in it
right and then we'd have to call that
when our program starts but we found it
we're gonna don't need to you know we
don't want to have to call
we want to just exist and that's where
this awesome
static keyword with the bracket comes in
again so that might be an a little trick
that you guys weren't aware of but yeah
so we'll add all these identifies it to
it now work fine so what we'll do here
is we'll go public on this isn't done by
the way but we'll go mmm public static
int get identifier okay and now we'll
return and identifier okay and this is
important as well
I'll just put 0 there for now now this
is important what we need is two more
things we need a private int private
static int index equals 0 we'll started
at 0 of course and we'll return IDs get
index now this is the other important
thing what this will do is this will
kind of return just want to return any
kind of random number at all this will
just return 0 then 1 then 2 & 3 & 4 & 5
if you want to return a random number
this is up to you you might just want to
do with you I don't know if why but you
might want to what you can do is there's
actually this awesome thing called
collections collections dot shuffle
again you can shuffle a list so I days
so what that will do is put them into
random order so then when you return it
at an index it will give you a random
number out of that range okay and the
important thing is it will never give
you the same number again this is what
incrementing the index here and we've
added you know we haven't added a random
number which added a bunch of numbers so
I'm gonna move this up to 10,000 just
for fun here and what I'll do as well as
I'll say if index is a greater if index
is greater than let's say if index is
greater than we'll go IDs dot size minus
1 then I guess we'll set index back to 0
and then we'll have to start reusing the
ones that we've used but that being said
this should give us a random number in
in the range of 10,000 or so okay
so if we go back to login not login
server sorry and then we we look at this
we can use his you idea I'll just
comment that out I'll leave it in that
because a lot of you guys might want to
use it but what I'll also do is I'll
just go ahead and call right over here
actually in our ID although all I will
do is call unique identifier don't get
identifier okay and that's it
okay that is it now we've got a million
different problems here with brackets
okay that that's it that's done so let's
say what that gives us
alright so we're still running the
client let's get rid of that
we'll start the server and we will start
the that was in the server that we
started seven-man my bad okay we started
the server yarn localhost
a-19 to login and you see that we get no
I didn't print it to the console like an
idiot
sorry about that bros that's over okay
so we'll go ahead and now every time you
call that you'll get a different number
by the way oh I forgot to do one thing
didn't I hang on
iDate so int ID equals of that hmm now I
think I forgot yeah once we return the
index what want to do is kind of
increment it now you guys might be
thinking okay well well then if I want
to increment it I can't just go like
that can I like that won't work because
I already returned something and yeah
won't but we can do is even pop it into
the bracket like this and then what that
will do is that will return index and
then it will increment it now if you
were to do something like this it would
increment the variable index and then
use it for the get method but doing a
post increment rather than pre increment
will make sure that it actually first
gets the idea at that index and then
increments be variable index okay sweet
so let's connect with two different
clients and see what numbers we get just
for fun so a server man launch that baby
go to login
and launch that young local host at one
man to login and what you see here is
absolutely nothing because I am freaking
tired today or something I don't know
what I'm doing here so let's make sure
we actually print ID to the console
otherwise I'm just wasting your time
I'll also just put the text identifier
next to it just so you can see a bit
more clearly all right so let's pull up
the console as well so you guys can see
what's going on even so so ever main
launch that it's already running let's
go to debug and close it done okay so so
main let's run that on that base go to
login and run that
alright so Y on localhost a one-line to
login alright so there we go we got an
identifier three eight four one OK
completely random Humber yeah cool done
so now let's launch another client and
see what we get now and also let's flip
the in debug I'll flip it off of the
console view back to these servers that
we can see it as it comes in so I'll
call this one churner in all caps for
some reason localhost 8 1 9 to login and
you can see that what we got here was a
completely different fire ok and it's
important to note that out of these
10,000 identifiers unlike if we did
something like new random dot next int
10,000 right this has a actually has a
chance to repeat itself this method that
we've just done will never ever ever
guaranteed repeat a number ever until it
gets up to 10,000 essentially once it's
done this 10,000 times ok yeah so that's
pretty much it guys I hope you enjoyed
this episode of network chef programming
what you could do is well just one more
little quick thing is when when a client
disconnects you could put their number
back into the array all right that's
also very possible so when they
disconnect you simply recycle that UID
and that way what you could basically do
is ensure that up to 10,000 clients can
be connected with
unique idea but that's not necessarily
for her our applications all I wouldn't
cover it unless you guys really want me
to
but anyway hit the like button if you
guys enjoyed this video
towards it likes one video tomorrow and
I'll see you guys next time goodbye